how's everything though I obviously got
the new album coming out this month
right every week bro we dropping you
know that's the thing with us right now
we're doing this line this year hashtag
PTA which is
the algorithms so we're dropping we're
dropping an album every other week every
other every two weeks there's an album
yeah so just dropping so for you
obviously you know we think of the Bay
Area I think of like independent grind I
think of independent rappers with 20 30
albums I mean you know for you what was
the
uh thought process behind
you know trying to figure out how to
adjust that Bay Area grind to the
algorithm too you know it's just PTA man
you know right now we're living in times
where you have hundreds and thousands of
artists that drop music
um consistently and it's so easy there's
no middleman now it's back in the day it
was hard to drop out right definitely
difficult to drop an album back then now
to take an advantage you have so many
different uh dsps and other other ways
to get your music to the masses right
um our main thing is just
I'm one of those artists where I really
love music I really love being in the
studio creating working and that's a
daily thing for me even in the midst of
all the other businesses you do it for
free I love it right so my main thing is
I still get high off creating you know
when I go in the studio I feel like it's
the my first day still right and I go in
there with something to prove I go in
there with something to create I'm not
one of those dudes that go in the lab
and just you know party both it's not my
thing I'm like dude I'm in here creating
right I really like and with my craft I
love it like that so saying all that to
say you look in your email you look at
hundreds and you know thousands of songs
like no they're just sitting
um why not put these out why not finish
them why not why just get them out yeah
you know get them out um and you never
know what can happen somebody can you
can wake up in the morning and your song
is going viral somebody has done a tick
tock tour somebody wants to put it in a
movie you know and as we grow and as we
expand and expound the others around us
that have been in the creative field
they do as well so you have directors
that may be working on music that may be
working on movies a lot of things in
Northern California right now
with you know the blind spotting Ryan
cougar is a childhood friend of mine and
these are people that reach out like yo
I need some music for this so why not
put it out man and you know like I say
hashtag PTA algorithms my biggest advice
to any artist out there there's no
perfect time to drop music so stop
waking yourself and stop fighting
overthinking it stop overthinking it you
know um and over uh analysts can cause
paralysis yeah and you'll be able to
stop and then you get tired of this
that you know it's hot because you're
like man it's just old now get it out
then it don't come out and then get the
music out man get the music to the
people let the fans decide push the
music out and if it don't work drop some
more you're not being held or held
accountable to all man your last project
was trash we don't want to listen to
nothing else man just keep working man
you know keep grinding man that's you
know if you're an artist and this is
what you love to do do it I love it man
um for you you've obviously evolved into
such a leader of the bay like when I
think of the Bay Area I think of you I
think a 40 I think of a couple guys who
just kind of like
I feel like on all levels being an OG
um I always see you embracing the
younger generation I always see you kind
of evolving the hustle whether it's
doing content Now with uh we're doing uh
the store the clothing line
um still obviously keeping your finger
on the post of the music for you
like what motivates you to
just keep the hustle strong man I feel
like you know it's it's in you it ain't
on you you know what I mean like I said
man I love it right you have to really
love what you do you know to continue to
do it especially when you're doing it
and it's not instant gratification it's
not instant right uh monetary you know
consumption and things like that we
really just do it man we love it you
know with me and Unk uh which he's here
he's gonna come on and and you know and
chill uh but embracing the younger guys
right showing the younger guys look it's
no age limit in it it's no there's no
expiration date and creativity
you know what I'm saying that's real and
and remain creative continue to keep
doing I tell people Quincy Jones helped
create Thriller at 50 years old
it's wild to think yeah I'm saying
that's that's one of his biggest
contributions
to music and one of the biggest songs in
music you think about the uh the Asian
dude who just won the best actors last
night he was like he was the little kid
yeah they hugged and reenacted kind of
like that same thing which is kind of
crazy yeah but that that's like that's
what it is like you know you look at
icons and legends like Nas winning his
first Grammy a couple years ago yeah
after all of the things that he's done
after after Illmatic and it was written
like yeah like we we look at these
things and we say look at what our icons
have been doing I I come under as you
alluded uh the e40s and you know the two
the two shorts Mac Dre's nicotineas and
the several of the the icons that have
done uh they have pioneered what it is
to be an independent artist right so
just following that blueprint and then
uh inoculating the things that I'm doing
to show some of the younger guys look it
don't have to just stop with music we
have a I have a clothing store I have a
nightclub I have a museum I have uh nail
shops I didn't know you had a museum
yeah the dope area experience so oh wow
um it's it's just a a canvas that we're
gonna um allocate to other schools and
everything we're opening up our school
and this summer The Dope Air Academy
which is just a a it's like a course for
to teach entrepreneurialism and other
things to help these people these young
kids jump the curve to be able to say
dude we got to start our kids early
right we got to start our kids in a
position to say dude let's get you in
the game early one thing with us in the
culture that we come from sometimes
our parents have taught us like you're
too young for that instead of
this is how you do it right right don't
touch that you're too young to that nah
we have to change that narrative and
break that monotony of not teaching and
not educating so I'm very you know I'm
huge on that so that's what all it is
with me man in a nutshell is just keep
leading that keep going and embrace the
Next Generation don't hog space so long
right and embrace Nick there's room for
everybody yeah come on man yeah for sure